what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to make this video to talk to you
guys about Patrian and and the whole
reason for this is because some of you
guys have expressed an interest some of
you guys have said that you are
interested and in someone like Patriot a
couple of you guys a lift comments some
of you have sent me messages and so on
another huge number maybe like 10 or 15
people and you know because of that I
figured you know why not I mean if
there's some relative interest in it and
then why not go for it you know why not
create a patreon page for those of you
guys who were unfamiliar with Patrian
this is basically a website whereby you
guys can donate to me like per month you
know for whatever works for you guys um
what I've done is is I've set like the
base amount at like three dollars so
it's like three dollars a month if
that's too much for you guys I can back
it off to like a dollar the whole reason
why I did this is because again you know
some of you guys expressed interest and
I know that some of you guys are of a
mindset where you feel like like you
want to give more something like that or
you want to contribute more that's fine
you know this by all means it's not
something that you need to do and I want
to make sure you guys know that you know
this is simply just something there if
if you guys want to I know that some
people that take advantage of Patrian
have a habit of being kind of crappy
about it you know like like doing things
like well you know if you donate like a
dollar a month like you'll get a shout
out on Twitter and if you donate like
three dollars a month like I'll follow
you on twitter and if you donate like
five dollars a month you'll get this and
so on and so forth and to me that's
that's kind of crappy I don't like
staging things and so what I've done is
it's basically like three bucks a month
and and you get pretty much everything
the way I've set it up with three
dollars a month you'll get access to my
videos before they go live on youtube so
you'll see them maybe like it like a few
days or a week i'm not exactly sure what
I've chosen you know what I'm going to
do for that the time frame but I may
just leave it to you guys to decide um
for that three bucks a month you guys
will get access to this private twitter
account but I've set up specifically for
people who follow me on patreon
we'll get together on skype or google
hangouts and we'll just kind of talk
about stuff we might live stream it you
know it depends on on what you guys are
interested in you know these are things
that I've that I've set up accordingly
you know i'll give you guys access to my
personal facebook page so you guys can
talk to me personally on facebook and we
can share back and forth and talk and so
on and so forth you know i like the idea
of having like I guess a community
within a community but again you know
this isn't something that that you guys
need to do you know for those of you
guys who don't want to be part of
Patrian it's not as I'm gonna ignore you
on Twitter you know a son is all I'm not
going to answer your questions on on
youtube and then I'm not going to stop
uploading to YouTube the videos are
still going to be here the videos will
still be uploading you guys will still
be able to see them you know just you
know just this is something for those of
you guys who were interested this is
something for those of you guys who want
to take advantage of it so again you
know I'm I wanted to make this video in
a way to where I guess I could do it in
a respectful tone because I think a lot
of people make these up a tree and
videos and basically what they do is
they get in front of a camera and they
say like give me money bye that's like
the gist of their videos you know and
and I try to be as honest as I can with
you guys and I try to make you guys know
we're gonna make you guys feel you guys
need you to know I try to make you guys
feel as though whenever I'm talking to
you that I'm talking to you like a
reasonable human being and I'm talking
to you like someone you could have any
kind of a conversation with and that's
why I've done this that's that's why I'm
you know talking to you guys in this
video is because I want you guys to know
again this is not something you have to
do and I know that there are going to be
some naysayers some people are going to
say well Rob you're just making a cash
grab it's three bucks a month there's
three dollars a month it's not a cash
grab i mean i don't i'm not expecting
you know 40,000 people to jump onto this
not at all you know i'm expecting like
maybe 45 people and yell
if that I mean I'm not expecting a whole
bunch of people so again you know this
is just just something for those of you
guys who are interested something for
those of you guys who who are looking to
be I guess would be part of a smaller
community you know who are looking to I
guess doing it you know to donate to do
more you know again this is just a total
this is totally up to you guys so i feel
like i'm groveling you know like guys
this I'm just doing this for the sake of
just being nice you have to believe me
anyway um that's really all I want to
talk about is just just let you guys
know this is something that I've started
up and of course and like we'll be down
in the description so you know a lot of
the things in terms of this page like
how it will grow and how it will
progress are things that I'm gonna leave
to you guys you know if there's other
stuff you guys want to see you know one
of the ideas that I've tinkered around
with is that you guys will be able to
join you know myself and Benny and Sal
you know for the post show on the weekly
pool you know when we're done actually
filming the weekly poll episode you know
I might hit one of you guys up on skype
and say hey like do you guys want to
join us for like half an hour or
something like that and we can just chit
chat and just ramble on about comics for
a little while you know and i'll upload
that segment two to you know the Patrian
portion you know to upload that directly
to patriot you know it may not be
something that's visible on my regular
YouTube channel where it might be you
know I don't know I mean these are
things that I'm leaving to you guys you
know this will be an entire thing that's
dictated for the most part by you guys
within reason if you guys are like you
know hey you don't be really cool Rob
and it's like what it's like if you got
if you came to like each of our cities
and visited us like that's not something
I can afford to do at the moment but you
know again this is just something for
fun just something that I think you guys
will hopefully enjoy so what that being
said I will catch you guys later